today I will be matching people to their
Subway sandwiches all right so we've got
three sandwiches here we've got a foot
long spicy Italian on honey oat meatball
marinara Subway melt so what are your
three favorite types of foods Cajun Soul
Food Italian she likes Italian so
there's the meatball marinara how do you
feel about
pickles I like pickles pickled onions
hi what's a pickled bunion how much
would you say you typically spend on a
sandwich on the sandwich itself I
usually get a cookie I get my own
macadamia nuts with it 12 bucks this one
was a very hard one I think I'm gonna go
with the spicy Italian on honey whatever
Subway milk kind of gal
oh my God